kum kum
est ce que tu vas t'en vas son village a
été revu ensemble nous avons pas d'abord
sur tes ennemis
il faut partir dépêchons-nous
j'ai l'impression que tu t'interroges
voulzy roi question pourquoi seulement
trois ans l'attendait plus pourquoi je
comprends rien du tout à ce qui se passe
c'est tout simplement le début d'une
histoire
la magie de ta mère était extrêmement
puissante
la mère a utilisé ses dernières forces
pour te sauver cobo et pour me donner
fille on fait quoi là nous devons
retrouver l'armure elle seule assurer
une protection
il ya fort longtemps je fus ensorcelé je
servirai mon destin
fait plus fort de jour en jour la magie
n'est pas censée être facile tu dois
exercice
une espèce de crâne heures
le reste me suivez moi
c'est ton héritage coupe
donne une fin heureuse à quand
l'histoire
si vous devez cligner des yeux
faites le maintenant
il va tout va
pourquoi
ferry parents photo
m
chut
foot us
comment
que vous soyez
e
non